hello and welcome to this video playing
a key they give each car or something
okay I'm playing something offbeat I
think this is a somewhat underestimated
move I mean see three it cannot be
fantastic but it has some points this is
one of the points where you simply grab
the pawn and say okay show me and black
is not easily getting the pawn back okay
now how do we do that from here he's
very relaxed about everything
g3 94 50 45 h3
it's definitely playable so let's go g3
just wonder sometimes people just like
completely just whatever yeah play
whatever okay but should be 4 V 5 H 3
takes takes on g4 takes takes
that's interesting
yes we might he might go back or Kim
don't know
one
you
so do this
don't really know
could a weird scribe message
okay so it's making a proper one-second
fries out of it
okay now
94 or is that too little developer and
say it could be just too little
development so let's put something
just-just-just develop develop something
okay d4 no it's not yet the threat
you
III young III he might play deform
interesting
what is best here Knight to b3 no that's
not a problem
we're surprised that
like black plug explain this very
quickly and I think there are some
interesting things to check and he does
that obviously very quickly I think he
playing he's playing it fine I'm just
just surprised that he gets when he
finds everything very quickly it's very
very good I would take longer here
considering things because they are
quite a number of I think points that
black should check
you know what to know there's
d4e for I don't know if II for for blank
is something yeah now now the position
becomes very static
have weak squares you know but I still
think it's good because it's so static
the bishop one g7 now is basically dead
it's a dead piece I know I know this is
all very passive but if I can
consolidate I'm fine again the bishop on
g7 will never do anything in this game
Mena's f5g five something truly
extraordinary
you
yeah that is something you should
consider really
five g5f for makes some sense
for
Oh
you
hmm I have to do that to consolidate
you know Kim and now you have to think
about a night coming to deform yeah I
can do that now maybe the bishop manages
to trade off for the night but I think
I'm reasonably well coordinated now and
the extra profit is a very healthy one
my structure is completely fine
still not easy to winnow anything
adjuster
requires precision to
get to some sort of conversion stage
my ideas c4
not certain what the doubling here what
that ultimately meant maybe I can do it
in a different way like this yeah now he
has to take this
and after that the d5 pawn is suffering
and now I'm up on the clock really
but it has a problem
now this is completely correct the
kingside now gets killed
g5 night at 5:00
you
and
but there's no way really to prevent it
and it's it's excellent for me
[Music]
yeah this one
threatening to take on g4
age six
is also going to be more than enough
[Music]
they can actually take first yeah
you can also take this now there are
many ponds I can also take this it gets
better and better
how many points is that five five points
in a row pending yeah then this is free
move its yeah it cannot be fantastic of
course I'm not going to sell you that it
has some ideas and I'm scoring quite
well with that and blitz chess sometimes
um one idea is that quite often people
somehow stumble into a Slav exchange and
they take and then all of a sudden
they're in a Slav exchange and they have
no clue where they started with C 1 C 5
that is something that can be
psychologically valuable get them into
some territory that they don't know and
I get actually this quite often where I
can take and say okay yeah what what
what exactly are you doing there do we
get to skip this pawn and um black can
get it back I think but it's not so easy
we know of this from the reti gambit and
I'm a I'm a full team coop and that is
in fact not easy from like you know you
can also do this it's offbeat ish but
it's it's very interesting you can you
can you can play this line and sometimes
people play this
after which I go into into a london
oratory with Bishop g5 again this is
nothing special but it is a little bit
different in terms of structure after c5
you know that black is ready for a
formal or for some for some more dynamic
play let's say oh this is more of a
static play so he never really I mean
even tried to get it back yeah here you
probably have to make a real pawn
sacrifice as he did and black does have
compensation there here I mean as I
mentioned during the game I think he
played it fine just and also very
quickly um you know ok Knight d2 the
engine wants to play III Knight F
teacher and things white is better I
wasn't sure I mean I wasn't shown 5/8
from each five
yeah a knight b3 I wasn't sure about
really what to do him maybe is three I
mean here he must have compensation I
mean enough compensation yeah III I'm
not sure about before that is a very
committal move and it could be that
sorry it is possible that I'm better
here now because it is such a static
position he only has these weaknesses to
play for what if I can cover that or
trade then it's not such a big deal for
black
the engine thinks I'm clearly better
basically
again I wasn't sure but it is definitely
possible
I think step by step now my position was
improving now we went a 5h for it here
we're getting to the point where it is
just comfortable night comes to that
good square and get here
I'm just step by step improving the
position
kingi six didn't help but it was already
I think beyond repair
it is a porn and I have the better
structure with the bishop understand
still looking very silly so it was kind
of kind of hopeless we have to get the
compensation somewhere around here he
definitely has some that I think is
quite clear okay guys thanks a lot for
watching